mit really turned to the visual arts
after world war ii when they started a
curricular visual arts program but also
an interest in bringing
public art to the mit campus
and this is really in many ways to
address a pressing institutional concern
that would escalate as the cold war
developed
which was how to humanize scientists and
engineers the first major
public art commission at mit was the
great sail
by alexander calder from 1965
and at the time calder was a leading
american artist
and is today one of the best known
american sculptors of the
20th century
came to mit in 1963
for a site visit and was very taken
with the sailboats on the charles river
and really wanted to bring that sense of
lightness and play into the campus
so you'll notice that even though this
sculpture the great sail
is uh 40 feet high and has 3 500 pounds
of nuts and bolts
alone it really has very few contact
points
with the ground and really does have the
sense of lightness
allowing people to pass underneath it
also has the important function
of creating this transition from the
human scale to the
massive gridded scale of impai's green
building behind it which is actually the
tallest building
in cambridge when you think of great
public art collections
you think of cities like seattle new
york and paris
what's amazing about the public art here
on campus is that
just that it's on our campus and it's
open to the public
and it's free for everyone to come and
to get inspired
when i was in high school i actually
worked at a sculpture park
in the area actually and when i first
visited mit
i did notice that there was art
everywhere
and i thought that i actually thought
for a long time that all colleges
had art everywhere and it wasn't until
like later that i realized how lucky i
was at mit
to have so much public art on campus
i think i didn't fully appreciate i you
know you kind of just assume
that all top tier universities are going
to have
arts programs like the one that you went
to but um
mit is really really special i think
especially the public art
is is really i think probably one of the
best in the country if not the world
public art at mit loosely operates in
two modes
one are the more freestanding sculptures
that you'll see as you walk around
campus outside
and these are many of our older
pieces such as the calder or
our bronzes by henry moore
the other mode of public art in our
collection
can be thought of as art as public space
and these are really works that are
meant to be
completed by the visitor in the sense
that they are
to be experienced through space and over
time
and it's really the presence of the
visitor that completes the work of art
now many of these works are cited
prominently in public
but we also have some wonderful pieces
that are
more somewhat hidden gems such as
our floor by sol the wit which is hidden
just off of the infinite corridor
you know you're walking through these
quarters of mit and then you kind of
turn this corner
and you you open the door and you see
this amazing floor
and there's catwalks everywhere and you
can go upstairs and you can see the
floor from
above as well so there's all these
different vantage points to enjoy the
artwork
when i was getting married our
photographers asked us you know
where in boston is special to you
because my husband
was actually a postdoc at mit as well
you know we immediately thought of mit
and i immediately thought of some of my
favorite public artworks so
we ended up taking a bunch of family
photos at the solarwind floor as well as
at the big sale
people are surprised that mit has such
an extensive public art here on campus
but it makes perfect sense in that to be
an engineer
physicist chemist it takes creativity
and to have such significant art around
you at all times
it promotes creativity so it makes
perfect sense that we have these major
pieces of art here on campus